Cuando surgió el telégrafo estaba claro
que iba a globalizar el mundo de las noticias.
Y esto, ¿a qué llevaría?
Bueno, obviamente, llevaría a la paz mundial.
La televisión, un medio que nos permitió no sólo oír
sino ver, literalmente ver, qué estaba ocurriendo
en otras partes del mundo, ¿eso a qué conllevaría?
A la paz mundial. (Risas)
¿El teléfono?
Adivinaron: a la paz mundial.
Siento decirlo, pero no trajo la paz mundial. Todavía no.
Incluso la imprenta, incluso la imprenta
se suponía que era una herramienta que impondría
la hegemonía intelectual católica en toda Europa.
En cambio, trajo "Las 95 tesis" de Martín Lutero,
la Reforma Protestante y, ya saben,
la Guerra de los Treinta Años. De acuerdo,
pero en lo que todas estas predicciones de paz acertaron
es que cuando, de repente, empiezan a circular
muchas ideas nuevas, eso cambia la sociedad.
Se equivocaron en lo que ocurriría después.
Cuanto más ideas hay en circulación,
hay más ideas con las que no estar de acuerdo a nivel individual.
Más medios siempre significa más discusiones.
Eso es lo que ocurre cuando se expande el espacio de medios.
Sin embargo, si nos retrotraemos a la imprenta
en los primeros años, nos gusta lo que pasó.
Somos una sociedad proimprenta.
Entonces, ¿cómo conciliar esas dos cosas?
nos lleva a discusiones, pero ¿nos parece algo bueno?
Creo que la respuesta está en este tipo de cosas.
Esta es la portada de "Philosophical Transactions",
la primera revista científica publicada en inglés
a mediados del siglo XVII,
creada por un grupo de personas que
se autodenominaba "El Colegio Invisible",
un grupo de filósofos de la naturaleza que sólo más tarde
se autodenominarían científicos,
que querían mejorar la forma en que
los filósofos naturales discutían
y para eso tenían que hacer dos cosas.
Necesitaban apertura. Tenían que crear una norma
que dijera, cuando uno hace un experimento
tiene que publicar no sólo sus afirmaciones,
sino cómo hizo uno el experimento.
Si no nos dices cómo lo hiciste, no te creeremos.
Lo otro que necesitaban era velocidad.
Tenían que sincronizar rápidamente con
lo que sabían otros filósofos naturales. De otro modo,
no se podrían mantener las discusiones apropiadas.
Claramente, la imprenta era el medio correcto para esto,
pero el libro era la herramienta incorrecta. Era demasiado lento.
Fue así que inventaron la revista científica
como una forma de sincronizar la discusión
en la comunidad de científicos naturales.
La revolución científica no fue producto de la imprenta.
Fue producto de los científicos
pero no se habría creado de no haber contado
con la herramienta de la imprenta.
Y, ¿qué hay de nosotros, de nuestra generación
y de nuestra revolución mediática, Internet?
Bueno, ¿predicciones de paz? Verifiquen. (Risas)
¿Más discusión? Premio de oro para esa.
(Risas)
Digo, YouTube es una mina de oro. (Risas)
¿Mejor discusión? Esa es la cuestión.
Por eso estudio medios sociales, es decir,
en una primera aproximación, veo a la gente discutir.
Y si tuviera que elegir un grupo que creo es
nuestro Colegio Invisible, es el grupo humano de nuestra generación
que trata de tomar estas herramientas y plasmarlas en servicio
no en busca de más, sino de mejores discusiones,
me quedaría con los programadores de código abierto.
La programación es una relación tripartita
entre un programador, algo de código
y la computadora que lo ejecuta; pero las computadoras
son célebres por interpretar instrucciones de forma inflexible.
Es extremadamente difícil escribir un conjunto
de instrucciones que la computadora sepa ejecutar
y eso si interviene una sola persona.
En cuanto pones a más de una persona a programar,
es muy fácil que cualquiera sobrescriba
el trabajo del otro si trabajan en el mismo archivo,
o que envíen instrucciones incompatibles
que simplemente provoquen un colapso
y este problema se acrecienta
conforme intervienen más programadores.
En una primera aproximación, el problema de gestionar
un gran proyecto de software consiste
en mantener bajo control este caos social.
Ahora, durante décadas ha existido una solución canónica
a este problema, que implica usar algo llamado
"sistema de control de versiones".
Y un sistema de control de versiones hace justamente eso.
Proporciona una copia canónica del software
de un servidor de algún lado.
Los únicos programadores que pueden modificarlo
son aquellos con permisos específicos para acceder al mismo,
y sólo pueden acceder a la subsección de código
sobre la que tienen permisos de edición.
Y al graficar diagramas de sistemas de control de versiones,
los diagramas siempre tienen un aspecto como éste.
Correcto. Parecen organigramas.
Y no hay que esforzarse mucho
para ver las ramificaciones políticas de un sistema como este.
Es feudalismo: un propietario, muchos obreros.
Está bien para la industria del software comercial.
Es el Office de Microsoft. Es el Photoshop de Adobe.
La empresa es propietaria del software.
Los programadores van y vienen.
Pero hubo un programador que decidió
que esta no era forma de trabajar.
Se trata de Linus Torvalds.
Torvalds es el programador de código abierto más famoso;
creó Linux, obviamente, y observó la manera en la que
el movimiento de código abierto había abordado el problema.
El software de código abierto, la promesa central de la licencia de código abierto,
es que todos deberían tener acceso al código fuente
todo el tiempo, pero claro, esto crea
la amenaza del caos que hay que evitar
para conseguir que algo funcione.
La mayoría de los proyectos de código abierto asomaron la nariz
y adoptaron el sistema de gestión feudal.
Pero Torvalds dijo: "No, no lo haré".
Su punto de vista sobre este tema fue muy claro.
Cuando uno adopta una herramienta, también adopta
la filosofía de gestión que conlleva esa herramienta
y él no adoptaría algo que no funcionara
a la manera de la comunidad de Linux.
Y para darles una idea de lo enorme
que era una decisión así, este es el mapa
de las dependencias internas de Linux
dentro del sistema operativo Linux, qué subpartes
del programa dependen de otras subpartes para funcionar.
Es un proceso sumamente complicado.
Es un programa sumamente complicado
y sin embargo, durante años, Torvalds lo dirigió
no con herramientas automatizadas, sino desde su correo.
Las personas literalmente le enviaban los cambios
que habían acordado, y él los combinaba a mano.
Y luego, 15 años después, al mirar Linux y analizar
el trabajo de la comunidad dijo: "Creo que sé
cómo escribir un sistema de control de versiones para personas libres".
Y lo llamó "Git". Git es un control de versiones distribuido.
Tiene dos grandes diferencias
con los sistemas tradicionales de control de versiones.
La primera es que hace honor a la promesa filosófica
del código abierto. Todo el que trabaja en un proyecto
tiene acceso a todo el código fuente, todo el tiempo.
Y al graficar el flujo de trabajo de Git
se usan gráficos que tienen este aspecto.
Y no hay que entender el significado de los círculos,
las cajas y las flechas para ver que ésta es una forma mucho más
complicada de trabajar que la provista
por los sistemas comunes de control de versiones.
Pero esto es también lo que trae nuevamente el caos,
y esta es la segunda gran innovación de Git.
Esta es una captura de pantalla de GitHub, el principal servicio de alojamiento de Git,
y cada vez que un programador usa Git
para hacer cualquier tipo de cambio,
para crear un nuevo archivo o modificar uno existente,
para combinar dos archivos, Git crea esta firma.
Esta larga cadena de números y letras de aquí
es un identificador único asociado a cada cambio,
pero sin una coordinación central.
Cada sistema Git genera este número de la misma manera,
lo que significa que es una firma infalsificable asociada
directamente a un cambio particular.
Esto tiene el siguiente efecto:
un programador en Edimburgo y uno en Entebbe
pueden ambos tomar una copia del mismo software.
Cada uno puede hacer cambios y combinarlos
después de eso, incluso desconociendo
de antemano la existencia el uno del otro.
Esto es cooperación sin coordinación.
Este es el gran cambio.
Pero no les cuento todo esto para convencerlos de que es genial
que los programadores de código abierto tengan una herramienta
que respalde su filosofía de trabajo,
aunque creo que es genial.
Les cuento todo esto por lo que creo que significa
en materia de unión de comunidades.
En cuanto Git permitió la cooperación sin coordinación,
se empezaron a ver formas comunitarias
enormemente grandes y complejas.
Este es un gráfico de la comunidad de Ruby.
Es un lenguaje de programación de código abierto
y todas las conexiones interpersonales
—este ya no es un gráfico del software, sino de personas—
todas las interconexiones entre personas
que trabajan en ese proyecto...
no parece un organigrama.
Parece un "desorganigrama" y no obstante
en esta comunidad, usando estas herramientas,
ahora pueden crear algo juntos.
Hay dos grandes razones para pensar que
este tipo de técnica puede aplicarse
a las democracias en general y en particular a la ley.
De hecho, si uno afirma
que algo de Internet será bueno
para la democracia, a menudo obtiene esta reacción.
(Música) (Risas)
¿Estás hablando del video
de los gatos que cantan? ¿Eso es lo que crees
que será bueno para la sociedad?
A lo que respondo que el quid
de los gatos que cantan es que siempre ocurre.
Y no sólo quiero decir que ocurre con Internet,
me refiero a que siempre ocurre con los medios, punto.
No pasó mucho tiempo luego del auge
de la imprenta comercial hasta que alguien
se dio cuenta de que las novelas eróticas eran una buena idea. (Risas)
No hizo falta un incentivo económico para vender libros;
mucho antes alguien dijo: "¿Sabes lo que apuesto?
que la gente comprará". (Risas)
Hicieron falta otros 150 años para que la gente
pensara en la revista científica, ¿sí? (Risas) (Aplausos)
El aprovechamiento que el Colegio Invisible
hizo de la imprenta para crear la revista científica
fue extraordinariamente importante, pero no ocurrió a lo grande,
tampoco ocurrió en forma rápida.
Para ver desde dónde viene el cambio
hay que mirar en los márgenes.
La ley también tiene una relación de dependencia.
Este es un gráfico del Código Fiscal de EE.UU.,
y la dependencia de una ley de otras leyes
para el efecto conjunto.
Allí está como sitio para la gestión de código fuente.
Pero también está el hecho de que la ley es otro lugar
donde circulan muchas opiniones,
pero tienen que resolverse en una copia canónica.
Y si vamos a GitHub y miramos los alrededores
hay millones y millones de proyectos,
casi todos de código fuente,
pero si miramos en los bordes, se puede ver a la gente
que experimenta con las ramificaciones políticas
de un sistema como ese.
Alguien puso todos los cables filtrados
del Departamento de Estado, junto con el software usado
para interpretarlos; eso incluye mi uso favorito
de las filtraciones: una herramienta para detectar
haikus naturales en la prosa del Departamento de Estado.
(Risas)
Correcto. (Risas)
El Senado de Nueva York puso algo llamado
Open Legislation, también alojado en GitHub,
nuevamente, debido a razones de actualización y fluidez.
Se puede ir, seleccionar un senador y luego ver
los proyectos de ley que patrocinó.
Alguien con seudónimo Divegeek subió el código de Utah,
las leyes del estado de Utah, y lo subieron allí
no sólo para distribuir el código,
sino con la posibilidad muy interesante de que esto pueda
usarse para favorecer el desarrollo de la legislación.
Alguien subió una herramienta durante el debate de derechos de autor
el año pasado en el Senado, que decía: "Es extraño que Hollywood
tenga más acceso a los legisladores canadienses
que los ciudadanos canadienses. ¿Por qué no usar GitHub
para mostrarles cómo sería un proyecto de ley ciudadano?"
Esta es una captura de pantalla muy evocadora.
Esto se llama "diff", esto de la derecha.
Muestra, en un texto editado por muchas personas,
cuándo se hizo un cambio, quién lo hizo
y cuál es el cambio.
Lo que está en rojo es lo que se borró.
Lo que está en verde es lo que se añadió.
Los programadores dan esto por sentado.
Ninguna democracia del mundo ofrece esta posibilidad
a sus ciudadanos para la legislación o para los presupuestos,
a pesar de ser cosas hechas
con nuestro consentimiento y nuestro dinero.
Me encantaría decirles que el hecho
de que los programadores de código abierto hayan elaborado
un método colaborativo a gran escala, distribuido,
económico, en sintonía con los ideales democráticos, me encantaría
decirles que dado que existen esas herramientas,
la innovación es inevitable. Pero no lo es.
Parte del problema, por supuesto, es sólo falta de información.
Alguien publicó una pregunta en Quora:
"¿Por qué los legisladores no usan
control de versiones distribuido?"
Esta es la respuesta gráfica. (Risas)
(Risas) (Aplausos)
De hecho, eso es parte del problema, pero sólo parte.
El problema más grande, claro, es el poder.
Las personas que experimentan la participación no tienen
poder legislativo, y las personas que tienen poder
legislativo no experimentan la participación.
Están experimentando la apertura.
No hay democracia que se precie que no tenga
una medida de transparencia, pero la transparencia es la apertura
en una sola dirección, y otorgar un tablero
sin volante nunca ha sido una promesa troncal
de una democracia a sus ciudadanos.
Piénsenlo.
Lo que llevó las opiniones de Martha Payne
al público fue una pieza de tecnología,
pero lo que las mantenía era la voluntad política.
Fue la expectativa de los ciudadanos
de que ella no fuera censurada.
Ese es el estado actual de estas herramientas colaborativas.
Las tenemos. Las hemos visto. Funcionan.
¿Podemos usarlas?
¿Podemos aplicar las técnicas que funcionaron aquí, allí?
T.S. Eliot dijo una vez: "Una de las cosas más trascendentales
que le puede ocurrir a una cultura
es adquirir una nueva forma de prosa".
Creo que eso está mal, pero... (Risas)
Creo que está bien para discutir. ¿Cierto?
Algo trascendental que puede ocurrirle a una cultura
es adquirir un nuevo estilo de discusión:
juicio por jurado, voto, revisión por pares, ahora esto. ¿Bien?
En nuestra vida, se ha inventado una nueva forma de discusión;
en la última década, de hecho.
Es en grande, distribuida, económica
y compatible con los ideales democráticos.
La pregunta ahora es, ¿dejaremos que los programadores
se la guarden para sí mismos?
¿O trataremos de tomarla para ponerla al servicio
de la sociedad en general?
Gracias por escuchar. (Aplausos)
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Gracias. (Aplausos)